and what an opportunity for him to start
his time here take a run see how far
it can go Wayne Simmons got in behind the
defense scores he just went hard to the net
Simmons between his legs scheifele can't get
it and coming in deep cross ranked the passes
behind his Target ovechkins behind the D Alex
Ovechkin speeding well leads in beautiful pass
hit the crossbar earlier about 10 seconds
before this and then blades across a pass
Falk moves up that's the Nick Letty defenseman
up on the play the pass into the slot the shot
and they score Barbershop is gonna drop
that through his legs pretty passing play
and then Barbershop takes the stick
approvroth out of the way at the same
brought back to Thompson tuck is along with
him and he'll take it after his tipped off
the stick on Tage Thompson this line is
dancing Skinner's gone nice little pick
there by talk opens up the lane for Skinner
he's going to curl and drag spark right there
[Applause]
puts it in through his legs drops it off for
Reinhardt gets into the slot he shoots omart
the same rebound bouncing around at the net
another shot and they say no goal holy cow
here's for Hagee digging for it there's the shot
through his legs on the backhand no doubt that's
a goal first periods have been a problem for
the Red Wings minus 12 bull differential the
chance for closure between the legs and scores
Drew knows he's well ahead of the class so he
says you know what I'm going to attack this woman
one on one and does so and me and Patterson makes
a move on Johnson goes around the goal Out
The Far Side backhandle [Applause] [Music]
thank you cadry sat on the puck and here's Lucas
Reichel in his third game of the season with the
big league club and Seth Jones down low rebound
score redirected fun and when it does that that
really tricks markstrom is he behind the Arizona
net ino in for stern what a say [Applause] scores
what a move what a save what a goal
sealer this way we listen to lining and just in
along the boards an attempt to the
side of the net Frost he's scores
of Beauty and the Flyers take a three one lead
Joshua from besser and Hughes the scoring play
at 11-34 connects with their first lead
and there's a shot that's why rebound
rebound a little Razzle Dazzle and the Canucks
are up by two as they score Devil's coming
out the other way this is a great crowd
tonight and they are rousing [Applause]
plastic comes through the big goal and it's just
a heavy floor check and look at that 50 little
backhand pass between the legs from Michael McLeod
now the Ducks will break out Harrington strome
oh my God he started again you've got Trevor
ziegas one of the most skilled young players in
the league able to do this pull the puck between
his legs towards Ryan strome trying to jam it
through Center ziegress Trails the play picks it
up between his legs great Passover to sweep into
the back and the Nets a nice finish by shattenkirk
but what a play by Trevor Secrets my goodness
with Mikey Anderson up on the rush Anderson
turns towards score [Music] [Applause] [Music]
[Applause] [Music] [Applause] has himself a
goal yeah beautiful pass and a nice finish by
Johanna that's the wrong line to turn
the puck over these days [Applause]
dropping it back off with the Rangers
changing nice move backhand shot
look at heat on the entry to the Zone not an
easy guy to get around and Backstrom drops it
in the perfect Spotlight from here through
his legs and on the back now Fox [Applause]
Adam Fox back out backhand shot
knocked in by quieter and for the initial shot
glass weaves it down low Parks it in
[Applause] [Music] what a move by Parson brings
it back up under the bar game set match what a
goal 22 years of age future is bright for this
kid and it's been the theme Contour stays out of
the ice as he moves up flipping around behind the
net try to dig it off the back [Applause] [Music]
right the chuck on the back side goes
between the legs in the empty net you
can see the Boston Bruins around they're there
but just not quick enough is that the creative
goal by Matthew could chuck they are set up today
[Applause] creativity the speed and how he makes
this So Graceful between the legs of one motion
but Broski tries to pop up but marchan goes down
quickly and how about that play White posture not
he's you know drifting that pocket I think he
was a little unsure of what was around it with
the pass between the legend and Markov scores
what a move now the Panthers tie the game at one
Jay Theodore
shift times at the bottom of your
screen BNR shot did not make it
through person across [Music] [Applause] [Music]